[Musique]
patrick bredas bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidat tête de liste pour la liste
l'alliance nouvelle au marigot et vous
avez 54 ans vous êtes employé à la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
vous avez été conseiller municipal de
l'ancien maire ange lavenaire et vous
étiez déjà aussi candidat pour des
élections municipales en 2014 et donc
cette fois ci pour 2020 vous conduisez
l'alliance nouvelle la liste l'alliance
nouvelle et expliquez nous tout d'abord
patrick bréda ce qui motive cette
nouvelle candidature a tout d'abord
bonjour aux auditeurs et auditrices de
martinique première est bien entendu au
marigot tino margotin qui doivent nous
écouter très attentivement
alors nous les élections 2014 ont donné
un résultat en 2014 nous sortons
troisième des urnes nous avons accepté
très démocratiquement que les maillotins
nous place dans cet espace nous y sommes
restés nous avons assisté à un duel
final les maïs bt ont choisi monsieur
perez joseph qui est l'actuel maire et
ont remercié l'ancien maire monsieur en
jeu l'avenir notre nom nous allons
essayer ce résultat il n'a pas été
décourageant pour vous non pas du tout
non nous sommes des démocrates nous
avons accepté ce que certains candidats
ont du mal à accepter à marigot mais
nous nous l'avons accepté maintenant les
margotin savent ce qu'ils veulent et
nous ont placés dans ce que je me plais
à dire dans la réserve dans la réserve
et en 2020 ils savent que nous sommes
placés nous étions placés l'an 2014 et
que nous aurons un rôle déterminant à
jouer pour les élections de 2020 donc
c'est ce que nous nous apprêtons à faire
en allant voir les marigots tient en
discutant avec eux en mettant en place
un certain nombre de choses et bien
entendu un programme qui puisse répondre
à leurs attentes ça c'est surtout notre
public on va on va y venir mais
ce qui a l'air de motiver quand même
aussi cette candidature donc de 2020
alors que vous étiez sorti 3e en 2014
c'est que vous jetez un regard sévère
sur la mandature de monsieur peraste qui
va s'achever là dans quelques semaines
vous n'êtes pas tendre avec le maire
sortant et son équipe sur le travail
effectué durant ces six années
alors s'ils voient que nous ne sommes
pas tendre avec le maire sortant
mais ça c'est les magots tel le voit au
quotidien
quand vous avez un maire et monsieur
perez lui même il le dit la proximité
c'est pas trop son truc
il faut savoir que quand on a été élu on
élu pour être à l'écouté de sa
population
allez tout le temps quotidiennement le
faire mais monsieur peyras c'est vrai
qu'il le dit il est dans ces dossiers et
la population à sa vaut il va pas
beaucoup sur le terrain au contact de la
culture et moi je passe tout le temps
chez les administrés nous savons ce
qu'il nous disait des quartiers où
monsieur perez n'est pratiquement pas
passé mais en dehors de ça ce que l'on
nous refusons au niveau de l'alliance
nouvelle c'est que monsieur perez en
2014 a en quelque sorte cacher la vérité
voyez je ne dis pas mentir et la cacher
la vérité à la population en faisant
plus de 50 de proposition et aujourd'hui
nous disons au moins deux au moins deux
et ça c'est cool au moins deux
réalisations qui faisait de réaliser sur
le marché y en a pas deux qui
recherchent toujours à voir et j'espère
qu'il aura l'occasion dans les
prochaines émissions de no2 où ça a été
fait en tout cas lorsque je vis le cher
le gerra a trompé à la machination
antoine tardif et routine je vais vous
dire deux trois choses très rapidement
est-ce que vous avez l'air de faire
entendre là mais bien sûr pour quand on
a proposé quand monsieur perez a proposé
aux jeunes dans moins de six mois
le stade serait remis en état qu'est-ce
qu'elle refait écouté par ses remarques
go ou regarder l'état du stade de
margaux d'autant plus et c'est là que
non nous portons des charges très très
convaincant
oui parce que ça passe très vite oui je
sais que
les grands thèmes de votre programme
alors nous ont bien entendu nous avons
plus le temps depuis 2014 d'écouté et de
rassembler un certain nombre de
propositions et ce que nous faisons au
malg auteurs se sont pas des promesses
ce sont des propositions à savoir on a
une difficulté on en mobilise population
à steve vieillissante à marigot il nous
faut d'un système de transport
interquartiers alors là je m'y attends
je sais très bien qu'il ya des
difficultés mais il ya aussi martinique
transpo et à cap nau même si c'est une
mission facultative mais au niveau de
cap nau nous pouvons trouver aussi des
financements vous voulez c'est qu'armand
d'imitation les proposer 100 à 80 oui
tout à fait l'arrière avec un arrière en
mettre en place un système de
transmission c'était un quartier tout à
fait et moi de sas est une priorité et
on va être jugés dessus parce que les
gens sont isolés et je vous assure que
pour faire un kilo mais tamargo c'est
d'une extrême complexité pour les
personnes les pour nos seniors
en dehors de ça la promesse que monsieur
p as a fait qu'il n'a pas été tenue nous
disons et patrick billet d'accession
équipe
il aura pas un stade à 2 millions
d'euros margot c'est pas vrai par contre
nous allons mettre en place un plateau
sportif et des avec une montée en
puissance des équipements et bien
entendu un financement pluriannuel pour
permettre aux margotin aux jeunes
talents de pouvoir s'épanouir en dehors
de ça nous avons cette population âgée
qui est là et qui doit être occupé
nous allons mettre en place une maison
de répit pour pousser personnes et bien
entendu avec les jeunes que nous avons
margot qui ont des spécialités
mécaniciens électriciens
nous avons en projet un garage solidaire
mais tout ça avec un emplacement déjà
réservé un réservés nous en parlerons un
peu plus tard mais nous sommes armés
pour 2020 avec des choses concrètes à la
dimension de la commune ultime question
qui appelle une réponse très très
courtes pattes patrick bride as est-ce
que vous habitez est ce que vous vivez
est-ce que vous travaillez à marigot
alors ouais le plaisir que j'ai
l'honneur c'est que je travaille je vis
à marigot je réside à marigot et je suis
dans le tissu associatif à marigot et ça
j'ai fait le choix dit elle et même en
2020 peu importe les résultats
jose saramago contrairement aux deux
meurt le sortant et l'ancien qui iront à
cette marie est abandonné
on les marie gauthier merci beaucoup
merci patrick bredas